today we're talking about new halo
infinite multiplayer details including
the upcoming beta how phasmaphobia has
changed the journal in a new update plus
we're going to break down the forza
horizon 5 multiplayer modes my name is
davonte chisholm and you're watching
gamespot news
let's kick things off with halo because
invites for the next technical test are
hitting inboxes and fan excitement is
through the roof 343 industries ran
through all the specifics in its latest
installment of the inside infinite
series and revealed weekend one from
september 23rd to the 26th will be 4v4
slayer meanwhile weekend 2 taking place
september 30th to october 3rd will
feature big team battle however don't
expect to be playing all day long each
test will only be available for a set
period of hours on each day to help test
servers against the highest concurrency
possible for more in-depth breakdown of
the time slots make sure to check out
gamespot.com
in other halo news 343 industries also
spoke about infinite micro transactions
and revealed cosmetic content isn't the
only thing that players can spend real
world cash on players can also buy
challenge swaps and xp boosts the
challenge swaps allow you to swap out
one of your weekly challenges and the xp
boost gives players double xp for weekly
and daily challenges the boost run for
30 minutes though this is a non-final
time as the game remains in development
however similar to cosmetic items the
swaps and boost can also be earned
through gameplay and other means at the
time of this recording 343 has not
announced the cost of the micro
transactions or the battle pass
and speaking of infinite's battle pass
recall 343 previously announced there is
no per match xp and there will not be a
separate xp progression system outside
of the battle pass at launch well during
the recent inside infinite 343
industries responded to the feedback
about this and said it is quote actively
exploring giving players more weapons to
progress through multiplayer beyond the
battle pass alone
but alright that's enough shooter talk
time for some spooky talk phasmophobia
developer kinetic games celebrated the
horror games one year anniversary and
announced an anniversary update the most
significant tweak in the update was the
journals makeover the journal is an
information resource in phasmaphobia
providing investigative clues photos
ghost info and more
now it's a little less clunky to use you
can cross off clues on the ghost
evidence page access the pause menu in
the journal and change all settings
using the journal other changes are
small edits like being able to see what
the ghost type was when you fail a
mission and no longer getting ten
dollars for failing a contract instead
receiving insurance depending on the
difficulty setting phasmophobia is one
thousand percent not a devante game and
i was terrified just reading that for
you but i'm excited for those of you
that are excited so
go get them and
happy one year anniversary kinetic games
moving on to something that is up my
alley forza horizon 5. during a live
stream the dev team introduced and
showed the game's different multiplayer
modes horizon arcade horizon tour and
horizon open horizon arcade is a
collection of mini games and will be
marked by pink circles on the map
players can team up together to find and
smash pinatas hit floating bullseye
targets and partake in simon says-esque
mini-games horizon tour is a more
laid-back mode consisting of a series of
drives and races on the map players can
form convoys with friends or new people
to take on the slower and relaxed
multiplayer mode and finally horizon
open is a take on the traditional
multiplayer and is the new version of
team adventure and online adventure from
previous games according to the dev team
they made horizon open a little more
accessible and fun and removed the skill
based ranking system in horizon open
players can partake in four activities
open racing open drifting playground
games and the eliminator battle royale
so let me know in the comments if you
got your email and if you're gonna be
playing in this upcoming halo beta
i think i forgot to verify my email
address so i wasn't in the insider
program in time to be in this one but
it's all right december it's right
around the corner it's right around
corner i'll be all right i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]